We work in a world of imagination.
As humans, we're always projecting
ourselves onto any characters that we see.
We may see Lightning McQueen as a car,
but we're still interpreting
that as Owen Wilson as a white male.
It's always really striking to me
that we can imagine talking cars,
but we can't imagine female NASCAR racers.
It feels like we should be
able to do this.
We should be able to do this.
But representation in the movie
industry has been an ongoing fight.
The world of animation is no different.
According to a report by the USC Annenberg
Inclusion Initiative,
only 17% of 120 recent animated films
featured female characters as the lead
or co-lead, and only 39% of 100 recent
animated TV series
featured a largely female cast.
Disney touts itself as a progressive
and diverse company.
Studies from their 2021 fiscal year
show their ongoing strive
for diversity in the workplace.
But this specific problem is less
about the people behind the screen
and more so about the characters
and speaking lines in animation.
My goal is to kind of normalize
seeing diversity on screen.
Being able to present
that on a large scale is incredible.
This is Jessica Heidt,
the department manager
of feature films at Pixar,
before managing the art department.
Her work in discoveries at Pixar changed
the way in which scripts were digested.
Several years ago.
I started a program
or a process of tracking gender
across our characters
and sort of trying to work with
increasing screen
representation and diversity on screen.
I got started in theater.
I worked at a theater
called the Magic Theater in San Francisco
because we were a smaller theater,
we were able to be
a lot more diverse in our choices.
I know personally as a director,
I was absolutely drawn to those stories.
My transition to Pixar
actually came directly from theater
because Mary Coleman,
who had been the associate artistic
director at the Magic
Theater, had transitioned over to Pixar.
She would bring me in
to do script coverage,
which was basically reading scripts
and writing analysis.
The continuous reading,
writing and analyzing
surprised Jessica,
after she noticed one major commonality.
I first noticed that
there was a discrepancy
between the male and female characters
when I was working on Cars 3.
What I was sort of feeling was that, "Oh,
this feels very uneven", and so I went in
and actually counted the difference.
And at that point,
it was 90% male and only 10% female.
It was so stark it became something
that I think I was unable
to step away from and say, "You
know, this isn't a problem".
I had gone back and tracked the data
across all of our films.
At that point where we were
was about 75% male
for speaking characters
and for the line count.
Take a look at Pixar's earlier movies
and one of their most popular
franchises, Toy Story.
With the exception of Andy's mom, sister,
and Bo Peep, virtually
all of the characters
and speaking lines are predominantly male.
When I finally was
able to present this to the executives,
I did it with a collection
of charts and graphs.
Because for me, being able
to take the emotion
out of what we were doing
and to just be able
to have them look at the numbers
and it was irrefutable.
I remember being absolutely terrified
in that meeting of just, you know,
handing them out and wondering
what people were going to say as this room
of of all of the top
execs were were in there looking at it.
Not only were the executives open
to hearing about Jessica's discoveries,
but they immediately
put a plan in action working together
to come up with the solution. As a studio.
We have the gift really, of working
with these incredible technical minds
as well as these storytellers.
And so every time you come up
with an idea of like, "Oh,
here's something I would like to change".
A technical wizard will come in
and say, "Oh, I can create a tool
for that to make it really easy
and really scalable".
I had some incredible allies, the biggest
and most amazing one being Josh Miner,
who is in our tools department.
He was thinking about it from a technical
point of view of like, "Is there
something that we can be doing
as an organization that might be able
to address these problems?"
And it was really Josh that said "Hey,
we can use this tool that we already have
in Pixar that we use
as script supervisors to track data".
Now this is something that the executives,
the producers, the directors, anyone
on any of the creatives on
any of our movies are now expecting
this information and it becomes part
of the conversation at every brain trust.
In 2019, Pixar created SparkShorts,
a series of short animated films
designed to give women and people of color
more opportunities in animation.
There was really a space
where the cultural moment outside of me
outside of Pixar really shifted,
and I feel like the momentum of
that was really something
that helped ricochet the work
that we're doing into the sort of level
that we're able to do right now.
Black Lives Matter
and #MeToo were those cultural moments
that catapulted a shift towards producing
more diverse and inclusive movies.
Pixar films like Coco and Soul showed the level of success when diversity
and representation are showcased,
and look at the cast of Toy Story 4.
Fast forward through the franchise,
and we see the introduction
and inclusion of characters like Mrs.
Potato Head, Jesse,
Dolly and characters like
Bo Peep were given more meaningful
roles in the main narrative.
In animation, it
takes so long to make our films,
so we are finally starting
to see the receipts
of the work that got started in 2016.
You know, in 2017, when we really, as
a studio, started paying close attention.
As you see the next films
coming out, you're going to be seeing
a lot more diversity on the screen.
I also think that we're starting
to see more women, more people of color,
more more people in the creative spaces
that are creating.
And I think that naturally leads
to more diverse representation on screen.
I know it's not always the big jumps
that we that we want,
but I feel like it's starting.